we know you like things done a certain
way Abby Lee Miller but would it really
be so bad to eat up on your junior
students we know you're preparing them
for the real world but sometimes you go
a little too far okay let's be honest do
you take things too far all the time
some of your former students refuse to
talk to you while others still call you
up to go on lunch dates
there's just no in-between say what you
will about Abby but she's still the best
in the business to say that Abby takes
things too far would be an
understatement watch until the end to
find out why Mia and Cameron are having
a hard time forgiving Abby for her
outrageous comments the cover-up Abby
Lee Miller says the meanest things and
sometimes her words are just too cruel
to showcase Dance Moms is notorious for
censoring their content and creating
fake scenarios and this is exactly what
happened during the season 4 finale the
editors reuse footage of a be telling
Kristen but in reality Abby made fun of
Chloe's medical condition telling her to
go fix her eye even the producers of the
show knew that Abby had gone too far
which is why they edited the clip in her
favor
sticks and stones if there's one thing
that puts Abby in a sour mood its losing
but her mood only intensifies when she
loses to her rival Cathy from the candy
apples Dance Center this is exactly what
happened in season 5 episode 13 after
beating the ALDC Cathy and her dancers
entered Abby's changing room to gloat
Cathy was holding the cake with Abby's
face on it and Abby wanted none of it on
her way out of the room Abby whispered
get those ears fixed to one of Cathy's
dancers while we understand that she was
upset Abby took things way too far when
she insulted an innocent and talented
young dancer not smart enough in season
5 Abby insulted Mackenzie's intelligence
in front of the entire oh gee squad the
pressure was on and Kenzie was having a
hard time remembering her solo Kenzie
was nearly in tears when she told Abby
that maybe she was thinking too much
that's when Abby took things a step
further and told her thanks
she even questioned Melisa about whether
or not homeschooling was a good choice
for her youngest daughter judgmental and
rude abby is known for her outbursts and
taking her frustrations out on others
and this is exactly what she did to
melissa in season 3 episode 5 Abby yells
at Melissa in front of her children
causing them to cry she tells Melissa
and she even scolds Melissa for getting
divorced and finding someone new happy
had no place talking about Melissa's
personal life in front of the entire
gang suck it up if there's one thing
Abby hates its crying children she puts
a lot of pressure on her students and
more often than not they break a lot of
Abby students have had panic attacks in
her studio but obviously Abby doesn't
know the difference between tears and
panic attacks Kindle was showing clear
signs of a panic attack in season 4
episode 13 but Abby brushed it off panic
attacks are very real and terrifying and
a dance teacher who takes care of
children should know how to handle them
the chair thro the Highlands never had
it easy with Abby but some would agree
that Kelly brought it upon herself in
season 2 kelly highlands got into a
fight with Abby because she forgot to
put stoppers on her daughter Paige's
chair
Abbey threw the chair in front of Paige
making her feel totally uncomfortable
and then tried to pin Paige against her
mother all in all Abby took things too
far and Kelly helped her get there all
washed up in season 2 Abby and Christi
faced off in the competition changing
rooms and things get ugly fast
Abby calls Chloe a snake and goes on to
tell Christine that her daughter will be
all washed up in five years and if that
wasn't bad enough Abby said this in
front of Chloe making her cry there's
always a favorite Abby had to learn the
hard way that plain favorites is a
recipe for disaster all the moms pay
Abby the same amount of money so she
should focus on all of her dancers
instead of just one Abby took things to
a whole new level by playing favorites
with Maddie
Kalani Brynn and Brady and choosing to
ignore dancers like Paige Nia Chloe and
Presley offensive comments it's a
well-known fact that Abby wants her
dancers to have neat hair which is why
Holly made sure to get approval for
Nia's hair when she had braided
extensions put in so when Holly
challenged Abby in season 2 episode 20
Abby chose to retaliates by making fun
of Nia's hair Holly and Nia were
rightfully upset over Abby's offensive
comments more offensive comments Abby
doesn't have a filter and on more than
one account Nia and Cameron have self
that Abby's comments were borderline
racist Kamryn bridges revealed that Abby
commented about her skin color and how
the bottom of her feet were lighter than
the rest of her body
Abby's comment made Cameron feel super
uncomfortable and it's not hard to see
why do you think Abby should change her
attitude or are her rude ways would make
Dance Moms so entertaining sound off in
the comments
[Music]
growing up on a reality show competing
was very stressful Maddie Ziegler has
come a long way since starring on the
Lifetime reality TV series Dance Moms
her popularity is on the rise and she's
the epitome of success but the road to
stardom hasn't always been an easy one
and Maddie's childhood is filled with
dark truths and surprising moments keep
watching to find out what really went
down on the set of Dance Moms young and
famous it's no secret that being under
the public eye is a super stressful
ordeal people follow you around seek you
out in a crowd take pictures of you and
publish faulty articles for your views
being a famous adult is hard enough as
it is
but being a famous kid can be even more
challenging Maddie Ziegler was only
eight years old when she first appeared
on Dance Moms
her whole life revolves around dance and
her life took a drastic turn right off
the bat at first being famous sounded
like a whole lot of fun but soon enough
the Ziegler's realized that fame came
with a price when Mackenzie had a
definitely rocky childhood the dark side
of social media during an interview with
cosmopolitan Melissa Ziegler opened up
about the dark side of social media and
how detrimental it can be for young
children not only were Mackenzie and
Maddie bullied online but some internet
trolls took things to a whole new level
by pretending to be them on different
platforms on top of that the Ziggler
sisters were constantly subjected to
negative comments and criticism which
can seriously affect young kids who are
still learning to harness healthy levels
of self esteem because she was always
compared against me in hopes of
preventing any mental trauma Melissa
made it a point to hire a social media
manager once her girls started to get
popular constant bullying it's being
bullied online wasn't bad enough both
Maddie and Mackenzie were bullied on the
set of Dance Moms while many of us are
quick to point a finger at Abby Lee
Miller whose teaching methods are
absolutely questionable
think about it avi wasn't the only
contributor since Maddie was Abby's
go-to dancer many of the dance moms saw
fit to talk about her behind her back
worst of all was the fact that Maddie
often overheard the adults fighting and
her name was dropped more often than not
this did nothing for Maddie's confidence
levels private tutors since being a part
of the Dance Moms cast was so demanding
many of the girls had to forego a normal
childhood
Maddie's freaking out because we're not
allowed to ice skate and that included
going to school like other kids their
age a normal day in Maddie's life
consisted of being followed around by
cameras she attended normal public
school for about three and a half hours
a day only to rush to the ALDC to start
shooting the reality TV show on top of
that Maddie attended dance class nearly
every single night and when her schedule
became too hectic a private tutor was
brought in to teach the girls in an
office down the road from the studio
she's homeschooling so that the mother
could get her here no time to be kids
since going to public school like normal
children was out of the question Maddie
didn't have a chance to make friends
outside of this studio
so her world literally revolved around
the ALDC on top of that every minute of
Maddie's life was accounted for going to
birthday parties or kicking back with
the girls on a Saturday night just
wasn't permitted instead Maddie and the
other dancers practiced their dance
numbers day and night from Wednesday to
Friday the girls were in rehearsals and
on Saturdays the girls would compete and
film all day most of the girls only had
Sundays off but even then they had to
study and get ready for the week I was
way more stressed than I am now throwing
up too fast not having the time to be a
kid is something that Maddie Mackenzie
and many of the other girls had trouble
with the girls that I don't get to do
fun things as much as we used to do as a
result they grew up too fast and were
subjected to huge amounts of stress
what do you mean you never leave dance
man Maddie Ziegler is far from being a
legal adult but her schedule is loaded
with endorsement deals TV appearances
and tour dates Dance Moms has many dark
truths and subjecting kids to pressure
and making them grow up too fast is just
one of them holds dancers back it's no
secret that Dance Moms is the perfect
platform for a recognition
it's how SIA found Maddie in the first
place when I met her it really just
skyrocketed from there and I'm so
grateful for everything she's given me
but despite helping dancers gain
popularity the reality TV series can
actually hold them back in the long run
during the same interview with
Cosmopolitan Melissa Ziegler talked
about what it really means to have a
contract with the TV series like Dance
Moms in the end her girls received many
offers and opportunities throughout
their time on the show you guys would be
really fantastic
obviously for commercials commercials
are great for kids unfortunately though
they were unable to pursue them due to
their binding contracts so when the
Ziegler's finally decided to call it
quits they were all very happy to be
moving on estranged friendships one of
the best things about Dance Moms is
building close relationships however
Maddie would soon realize that her
longtime friends were bound to the show
when you're a part of the Dance Moms
crew you literally spend all of your
time at the ALDC so once you leave Dance
Moms you don't really get to see your
friends anymore it's just need to think
about our two sisters leaving Maddie was
super close to Kendall and Chloe but
sadly their friendships took a hit after
the Ziggler's left Dance Moms mental
health issues but perhaps the darkest
truth of all is that being a part of the
Dance Moms cast could potentially lead
to mental health issues via Thailand and
Kendall vertes both suffered from
anxiety attacks throughout their time on
the show and many of the other dancers
are reported feeling overwhelmed and
mentally and physically strained she's a
little girl seven hours of dances a lot
since the show revolves around preteens
competitions yelling and fighting it
would have been a good idea to have a
child psychiatrist on set
unfortunately this just wasn't the case
what do you think is the best and worst
part about being on Dance Moms sound off
in the comments section
[Music]
you might have a bad reputation Abbi but
that's never stopped us from cheering
you on without you dance moms would
never have become what it is today your
comebacks your no-nonsense attitude and
your fiery energy have turned us into
total Dance Moms fans we heard the
audition process isn't an easy one to
get through so tell us Abby what do you
look for in a dancer and don't say
Maddie Ziegler because that ship has
sailed the old and new Dance Moms cast
went through a lot to win their spots on
the show and every single one of them
deserves to be where they are today but
just how far do moms have to go to win
their kids a spot on the show watch
until the end to find out it is a dream
come true there's no room for good Abby
Lee Miller doesn't pride herself on
students being good enough she prides
herself on them being the best so if she
sees any mediocre dancers auditioning
for a spot on her show she won't
hesitate to send them home this adds
loads of stress to an already stressful
event in many young dancers lives Dance
Moms in the making Abby Lee Miller might
be searching for the next Maddie Ziegler
but the show's producers are looking for
the whole package they want to tell in a
dancer who has a mother that fits their
desired profile during the audition
process the moms can be seen telling
their kids just how important their
auditions are
it's not good today it's great today the
kids look stressed out and nervous but
that's no surprise these one of the
dance moms are turning up the heat on
audition day after all if they're kids
below it they'll miss out on an
opportunity of a lifetime you're
competing against the best before ever
making it into the audition room dancers
need to send in an application form
we'll go over this jaw-dropping
application for him at the end of the
video so don't go anywhere since Abby
wants to make sure that she doesn't
waste her time
dozens of dancers are handpicked by
producers before being brought in for
auditions if a dancer gets a callback
and is asked to audition in person they
know that they're competing against the
best dancers throughout America no one
is safe during the audition process for
season 8 Abby Lee Miller mentioned that
she was keeping three girls from season
seven on the team but Abby made it clear
that they weren't when it comes to
audition day nothing is set in stone a
dancer could be given a spot on the show
only to have it taken away when a better
dancer comes along young and confused
there's nothing wrong with starting
young in fact most dancers start paving
their paths to success at a very young
age but some of the dancers auditioning
for Dance Moms season eight seems a
little confused while their parents knew
exactly what was going on and what was
at stake some children looked lost and
confused the dark truth about the
audition process is that some mothers
push their kids too hard too fast the
application form before getting the
chance to dance your heart out in front
of Abby Lee Miller and the rest of the
crew dancers need to fill out an
application form the forum is designed
to find out about the dancer their
mother and their family life Abby wants
to know how old the dancer is which
studio he or she dances at and what
their parents do for a living this last
one might sound a little invasive but
Abby wants to make sure that her dancers
parents can support their child should
they make it into the ALDC you have to
sell yourself while it's the kids who
will be competing for a spot on the show
it's their mothers who need to sell them
to the studio
parents are asked how good their kids
are on the application forms and moms
are supposed to rate their kids from ten
to one but in reality the ALDC is
looking for mothers who go the extra
mile and write something like Maddie
Ziegler might be a 10 but mike is an 11
how determined are you if you want to
win a spot on Dance Moms you need to
prove just how dedicated you are the
application form is designed to we now
undead ik ated dancers dancers are asked
to describe just how much dance means to
them Abby wants to make sure that dance
is the most important thing in their
lives or else she's not interested in
casting them the competition Abby Lee
Miller wants to find the diamond in the
rough she wants a confident classy and
talented dancer to earn a spot on her
team and to find this dancer Abby asks
the kids who their biggest competition
is in the whole wide world to make it
through this question kids are supposed
to answer with dance icons like Jennifer
Lopez Beyonce or Maddie herself the real
deal but when it comes down to it the
producers of Dance Moms are looking for
drama at every turn and they want to
make sure that moms are going to turn up
the heat so the most surprising question
on the application form is directed at
the mothers they're asked to reveal
which og dance mom they would bump heads
with the most this way the producers can
get a sense of their personality so
there you have it guys the dark truth
behind the dance moms audition process
who's your favorite dancer from season 8
tell us in the comments you Dance Moms
are so predictable and the longer you
appear on Dance Moms the more
predictable you get Christi we know you
can't take it when Khloe gets criticized
but do you always have to blow up before
Abby finishes her sentence and Holly why
do you look so painfully worried every
single time Nia steps out on the stage
we've picked up on your habits and
filming mistakes and we're about to put
them on display it's so easy to get
distracted by all of the drama on Dance
Moms but if you dig a little deeper
you'll surely start to notice a handful
of things that most people miss watch
until the end and let us know how many
of these things you noticed and how many
of them you missed
[Applause]
same costume different solo coming up
with new and improved costumes every
single week can be downright impossible
this is especially true considering that
many of the dance moms had to fabricate
their own costumes did any of you notice
that Maddie was wearing the exact same
costume for her angel and Manhattan
solos costume mishap
once again we're on the subject of
costumes but this time we're looking at
mckinsey not Maddie during the winters
war performance Maddie twirled Kenzie
around and a piece of her costume fell
off the girls didn't seem to notice but
some eagle-eyed fans immediately saw the
white ribbon fall off of Kenzie's dress
Holly's facial expressions watching your
daughter perform onstage can be a whole
lot of fun but when it comes to Holly
it's safe to assume that it's a
stressful ordeal everytime Nia has a
solo
Holly watches from the audience with the
exact same look on her face her lips are
pursed into an O and her hands are held
up in a praying motion Callie's crazy
eyes but Holly isn't the only dance mom
who gets a strange look on her face
while her daughter is performing a solo
have you ever noticed I Kelly gets a
classic case of the crazy eyes every
time she watches Brooke and Paige
perform say what you want about Kelly
but her daughters are her pride and joy
last-second wardrobe changes in season
four
Kinsey's outfit went from put together
to lacking before our very eyes during
rehearsals Kenzie is seen wearing long
black gloves but when she performs her
number
love overdose the gloves are nowhere to
be found we wonder why she chose to
ditch the gloves
ninety beat Kamryn Maddie's been winning
solo titles since she was a little kid
so it came as no surprise when she won
first place in season two episode 20 but
what did come as a surprise was seeing
Kamryn in the background turns out that
Maddie and Cameron were competing for
the same title and Maddie won by a
landslide
surprise surprise superstitious Maddie
it's no secret that the cast of Dance
Moms is a little superstitious the girls
had a special handshake that they would
perform before going out on stage as
well as a few favorite lucky numbers but
when it came to scoring solos Maddie
took things to the next level
Driver solo did any of you notice how
Maddie crossed her fingers before Abby
announced the week's soloist pyramid
swap pyramid days are tough for everyone
but apparently they're so tough that
Abby has a hard time keeping track of
who goes where despite Kalani being
placed at the bottom of the pyramid and
Jojo being placed in the middle row the
girls pictures get swapped by the end of
the scene who else noticed this pyramid
day mistake tell us in the comments
reusing costumes remember when we said
that Maddie used the exact same costume
while performing Manhattan and angel
well she did it again during the group
dance Frost you can clearly see that
Maddie is wearing the exact same white
outfit in season 4 episode 13 we wonder
how many times Maddie actually reused
that classic look Kendall in the
background it's common knowledge that no
one is supposed to be on the stage
except for those who are performing well
it looks like Kendall missed this lesson
because we clearly see her on stage
during the mini mimes performance in
season 6 episode 27 Kendall only appears
for a few seconds but her braids are
super recognizable the producers
misspelled Kendall's name here's
something that not a lot of people
noticed during Kendall's bring on the
boys solo you would think that the
producers of Dance Moms would dot their
i's and cross their TS but during this
episode they totally forgot the second L
in Kendall's name
we wonder if Kendall herself is aware of
this typo two places at the same time
it's no secret that the producers of
Dance Moms alter their footage to make
it look that much more dramatic do you
guys remember when Vivi's said the wrong
Studios name in season 1 episode 3 well
there's evidence of footage tampering in
this episode thanks to Mackenzie at
first she's on the stage with vivvy but
when we see Abby's reaction to Vivi's
mistake Kenzie is in the audience
Jill's the worst and best dance mom if
there's one thing Dance Moms fans have
noticed it's that Jill is the biggest
hypocrites and instigator of all the
Dance Moms what genre is it anyway the
show's producers made another mistake in
season three when they labeled Kenzie
solo as contemporary during rehearsals
Abby made it clear that kindy solo was
acrobatic Abby gets taken aback if you
thought that Abby wasn't scared of
anything you were wrong turns out she's
scared of minister dawn but we can't say
we've really blame her
look at how Abby jumps when Don yells at
her from behind and that's a wrap let us
know what your score is down below
thanks for watching the things be sure
to give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button see you next time
[Music]